[Musik]
ja geil ich habe mich 2004 noch als deko
echt richtig saftig keinen zusätzlichen
zucker oder häuser gar nicht wie
hallo ihr lieben heute machen wir etwas
das auf handys mit gewachsenes
durchschnitt von agennix das ist auch
ein junges gemüse gekauft wir waren bei
kaufland ein bisschen wocheneinkauf
machen und ich meine das ist immer so
wenn wir unterwegs zum einkaufen durch
die gänge reden wir immer darüber was
wir als nächstes ab film und ich meinte
dann so ich habe richtig lust mal wieder
auf so schnitten vom blech haben sie so
beliebten hobby filmangebot 4 + 1 gratis
nimm das damit und zauber mal was
schönes draus und gehört deshalb gibt es
heute richtig leckere toffifee so keine
produktion dazu ins oder nein das ist
keine chance auch immer wieder gerne
wenn ich leute soll ich denke dass es
sowohl video ist genau das ist einfach
so weil wir bock drauf haben warum auch
nicht also kaffee schmeckt ja auch echt
gut so und jetzt fange ich direkt an ich
schreibe euch wie immer alle ganz
genauen mengenangaben unten in die
infobox und da fange ich jetzt direkt an
ich habe hier ein wasserbad vorbereitet
das heißt ich habe einfach kochendes
wasser in meinem kopf gegeben gibt eine
schüssel obendrüber ruhig eine schöne
große nähe machen wir gleich direkt
weiter in der schüssel das wasser muss
die schüsse jetzt nicht unbedingt
berühren wir wollen ein bisschen hitze
und da kommt jetzt butter rein und
zartbitter kuvertüre falls es einige
unter euch gibt jetzt seinem beispiel
noch mehr vollmilch fan kann ich auch
voll mich nehmen dürft ihr zwar aber
vertraut mir wegen der süße damit es
halt einfach angenehm schreck gleich
kommt dann noch zucker dazu empfehle ich
euch auf jeden fall zeit bitter zu
nehmen sodass das ich jetzt schön
langsam schmelzen doch dann vom herd
lass es kurz runter kind vor die eier
dazu kommt natürlich ein ruheraum und
dann geht es weiter
[Musik]
jetzt konnte die butter schoko masse
schön runterkühlen sie kann wirklich
noch handwarm sein jetzt gebe ich auch
schon mal zucker mit dazu und dann
nacheinander die eier und bei den eiern
ist dann wirklich mal sofort umrühren
wenn wir einen freien trug damit wie
gesagt eben also wie gefeiert jetzt
sowieso nicht mehr groß dadurch dass
abgekühlt wurden aber es ist doch besser
wenn wir sie gefragt sagt immer direkt
mit der masse verbinden
ja genau also man muss jetzt keine angst
haben weil es sowieso runtergekühlt aber
es ist halt noch handwarm und man muss
sich die einschlagen und dann zehn jahre
warten oder so nah so schon hier richtig
auf zack sein
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt noch die trockenen
zutaten schön dazu gesehen einmal
kräftig umgerührt und ganz zum schluss
kommen auch haselnuss kern hinzu so
typischen fehler da ist der inneren auch
leckere haselnüsse und jetzt habe ich
auch schon im ofen vorgeheizt auf 190
grad oberen unter hitze und es geht an
den bug rahmen ich habe hier meinen ba
kram mit der klemmung das auch nichts
verrutscht und ich habe ja auch in ein
waldstück zur klärung das hat wirklich
sie käme es doch etwas neues aus nein
das ist nichts neues aber viele haben
ihn schon zu hause und schreiben wir mal
dass die super happy mit dem sind ein
jahr oder somit auf jeden fall mega und
der hat auch eine innen skala damit wir
in schichten sicher dass alles schön
gleichmäßig es aber wir brauchen bei
diesem rezept die außen skater sondern
da wird ja aber es ist wirklich cool
denn ich hab jetzt eingestellt kann ich
mich einfach nachgucken 26 x 22 cm
da gebe ich jetzt einfach den teig
reihen der verstreicht sich quasi fast
von alleine glatt aber ihr könnt gerne
noch mal ein bisschen nachhelfen und ich
habe unten drunter mein grades gelocktes
backblech falls ihr sowas nicht da habt
und euer wacklig ist ein bisschen uneben
oder hat irgendwie eine wölbung oder so
dann kann es immer mal sein dass so ein
bisschen mehr teig ausläuft um das zu
vermeiden könnt ihr auch alba kam so ein
bisschen papier einschlagen so aber ich
hier ist das vorbei aber das wirklich um
das ist genau das wo man nur wenn es um
das guthaben wie du bist ein [ __ ] profi
geworden dass es mir richtig aufgefallen
so jetzt immer schön in die ecken
verteilen hier sah und dann wird schön
gar gebacken
[Musik]
so wir machen jetzt die leckeren dafür
habe ich einfach am vortag was
vorbereitet aber eben müsstest und im
vortrag vorbereiten es geht auch wenn
ich nur für zwei stunden kühlt und nicht
die ganze nacht passiert einfach so
ergeben und zwar nehmt ihr euch einen
topf und erwärmt sahne darin ganz ganz
wichtig last ist nicht hoch kochen sonst
funktioniert das ganze nicht mehr nur
erwärmt und dann nogat dazu geben findet
in jedem supermarkt und da könnt ihr
dann einfach das ganze schön erwärmung
miteinander verschmelzen lassen und dann
habt ihr dieses ergebnis das muss dann
natürlich noch mal richtig schön gekühlt
werden denn das ist der wende wird seine
die wir aufschlagen wollen und das
funktioniert nur wenn sie ganz ganz kalt
ist und die ist bei mir so zu kalt es
geht halt und da gebe ich jetzt einfach
die komplette saal lockert mischung hier
in meiner rührschüssel es ging auch mit
einem handrührgerät dauert noch ein
bisschen länger so und dann schlage ich
das richtig schön steif erstmal langsam
und dann auf maximaler geschwindigkeit
[Musik]
für den look ab wann ist fertig und ich
habe extra kein wahlverein gemacht weil
ich möchte dass sie so richtig schön
weich ist und mein boden ist auch
ausgekühlt das heißt wir können
eigentlich das ganze schon mal fertig
stehen ich nehme jetzt noch mein
backform löser das bewirkt einfach dass
ihr schon mal den teil von wagram
entfernt das euch da eben nichts
hängenbleiben ihr euch den teig nicht
weg oder kaputt sondern kommt das ganze
auch schon auf meine servierplatten im
da immer meinen eckigen kuchen hemer mit
kraft und dann kommt die nur zahlungen
drauf
[Musik]
jetzt kommt natürlich noch der krönende
abschluss natürlich toffifee verklemmte
und nehmen den der toffifee gebe ich
dann auch ganz unregelmäßig haselnuss
kerne darüber und wenn ihr mögt könnt
ihr noch karamell dazu geben einfach nur
jetzt für die optik aber ich muss sagen
auch für den geschmack wenn ihr ein
bisschen mehr drauf gibt dann schmeckt
natürlich auch noch mal schön ordentlich
nach karamell und ich finde dass mehr
brauchst gar nicht bei den haselnuss
kern dem ich meine eigenen das sind die
gleichen die in kiesgruben hazel und und
schoko drin sind und die sind doppelt
gerüstet und schmecken richtig gut die
welt jetzt aber wahrscheinlich auch noch
mal so ein bisschen hacken durch die
michael betreiber vielleicht auch ganze
mal ganz spontan
[Musik]
wir probieren jetzt im griff die
automatisch machen und habe ich ja
verkackt wir werden jetzt die techniken
ich mich drauf ich finde diese herz und
versuchst du gemacht hast er könnte
einfach die toiletten mit pünktchen
machen und von einem zahnstocher entlang
einfach beträgt der welt sie müssen so
dann probier mal das prachtstück also es
geht auch echtes muss kuchen durch und
ich bin sehr gespannt auf die ich mich
freue mich zwar noch als deko du nicht
spielst du sagst
[Musik]
das rennen stand ist das was google
google + co ja stimmt das so dieser
dämonen mit müssen war der boden ist
extrem saftig echt richtig saftig und
diese knackigen nüsse com perfekt durch
aber was ich genial finde ist diese zwei
zutaten creme
tibet fahne und magath keinen
zusätzlichen zucker
gar nicht
richtig lecker und es ist das ist für
mich einfach locker 6 1 was ich nun
grund nur in unser team braucht genau es
stimmt du fehlst du mit dem car am ende
auch schönen krönender abschluss alle
die manager soße dahin haben könnte es
gerne benutzten nimmt gern karamell
eurer wahl ich bin trotz ramadan eurer
wahl ist sehr lecker auch mit dem
messemotto perfekt und da wird's heute
ist das manchmal abschlossen haben auf
jeden fall dass die geselligkeit das
wirklich sehr leicht und nicht zusieht
ich bin auf wolke sieben also wir genug
gequatscht wir uns überlegt für alle die
immer so bis zum ende bleiben und die
ist unser ganz gelassen
also in diesem video oder während sie
das hat sich etwas verändert wie bei
diesen vorher nachher suchbildern wo in
zukunft anders so schwierig dieses
bemerkt haben was anders ist
kommentieren das jetzt einfach zum spaß
und das hat sich im laufe des videos
geändert optisch sternen oder sein dass
hier weil sich das kreis da war ja doch
dort kommentiert dass auf jeden fall ich
bin jetzt
das ist die haare anders habe mir das
auf jeden fall könnt ihr dann
kommentieren in landet automatisch im
lostopf und unter allem die richtig
geraten haben da warten wir mal vier
fünf werktage ab tagen fünf im shoot
modus da waren wir vier fünf tage ab und
da können alle diesem los doch drin sind
1 50 euro gutschein gewinnen insgesamt
verlosen 3 durch einmal 50 europäische
wirtschaft viel geschafft habe leute
lasst uns mal eine woche zeit so jetzt
lassen wir euch aber gehen wünschen euch
ganz viel spaß beim nachmachen kommt
gerne zurück zum video und schreib mir
beton mit euer feedback welches bestimmt
genauso wie wir haben jetzt schon
komplett weg geatmet und ich genieße
mein stück jetzt auch mit einem latte
macchiato sage nicht nein gesagt das
muss also bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]